So one of the most common debates you'll read
about online, in books, videos, newspapers,
all over the place is are entrepreneurs born,
or are they made?
And who's right?
This thing gets heated.
You'll sit at tables and you know, everybody's
born as an entrepreneur.
Elon Musk was born with SpaceX, PayPal, and
Tesla and John Doe, even though he doesn't
know what he's thinking about, he can one
day become an entrepreneur.
Hopeful, wishful, they can become one.
You can do it.
There's no way you're only Elon Musk or you're
not.
Who's right?
So I think the first thing we need to do,
I was having dinner this past week, Thanksgiving
had friends and family over.
And one of the topics that came up was love.
Somebody brought up a question about hey Pat,
what does it take to run a nonprofit organization
where you're not paying anybody salaries,
for instance, how do you get a volunteer army
to be excited about it?
One of the most important things is love.
I said, "But here's a question.
Let's define love."
And I asked everybody one by one by one to
give their definition of love.
Watch what happens.
There's 12 people around the table.
Do you know how many different definitions
we got?
We got eight different definitions of what
love is.
Everyone said something different.
Unconditional.
Sacrifice.
Quality time.
Everybody said something different.
Now watch what the problem is here.
This is one of the reasons why relationships
sometimes don't work out.
My meaning of love is different than your
meaning of love.
Then we clash.
So you say, "You don't love me anymore."
You don't love me anymore.
I don't love like you do.
You don't love like I do.
You don't love me the way I want to be loved.
So today we're going to start off by first
defining what it means to become an entrepreneur.
You see, there are a lot of different definitions,
but I wanted to go to the top two sources,
dictionaries, Oxford and Cambridge.
Let's see how they define what it is to become
an entrepreneur.
Cambridge: A person who attempts to make a
profit by starting a company or by operating
alone in the business world, especially when
it involves taking risks.
This is Cambridge.
Now let's look at Oxford.
A person who sets up a business or businesses,
taking on financial risks in the hope of profit.
This is what they're saying.
The word profit is used.
The word risk is used on both definitions.
So, okay, since we know it has to do with
starting a business, having a risk and possibly
the desire is to go out there and create a
profit, phenomenal.
But how many different things do we hear about
what it is to become an entrepreneur?
You'll hear a lot of people say, entrepreneurs
are creative.
They're problem solvers.
They're visionaries.
They want to find things to do better.
They're leaders.
They're great sales people.
They're energetic.
They're charismatic.
They're just so, their eyes go all over , they're
bouncing all over the place.
Every time you talk to them ding, ding, ding,
ding.
They can't stay on one thing.
They get bored quickly.
They're hypomanic.
All these things we hear about, on what it
is to become an entrepreneur.
They're artists.
They're calm during pressure.
They're resourceful.
Okay.
We hear all these things.
Does that mean they're born?
Or does that mean they're made?
So let's go first why they believe entrepreneurs
are born.
So the argument is typically made by two different
people that make the argument about being
born.
One is, those who tried it and miserably failed.
They lost everything.
So it's an argument to say, I failed, and
because of it, entrepreneurs are born.
And the other one is they were somebody who
became successful and they fully believe they're
smarter, they're stronger, they're faster,
they're better than everybody else in the
way they think.
So in a way, those who become successful,
they think they're better than other people,.
in one way or another.
It's almost becomes an elite status, where
there's this elitist feeling to say, I think
better than you, therefore, I was born to
become an entrepreneur, you were not.
Here's another thing with entrepreneurship,
those who think they were born.
There's another mindset that says things like,
you know, where they forget sometimes when
you become wealthy, and all of a sudden you
go from having no money to all of a sudden
you're worth $100 million, $200 million, a
billion dollars.
What happens is everybody starts telling you
how amazing you are.
It's a very, very dangerous thing.
By the way, most people don't know what it
is to have people tell you this.
It's just like when people say, "I cannot
believe such and such, you know, slept around
and he did this, this, this, this this."
For example, whatever argument it is.
Do you know what it is to be the hottest guy
in the world, where every magazine tells you
you're the most handsome guy in the world?
Don't you think it would mess with your head
a little bit?
Think about if you're a girl, and every magazine
tells you you're the most drop dead gorgeous
girl in the world.
How would you walk?
I want you to think about it right now.
Millions of people around world tell you you're
amazing.
How do you walk?
Do you walk like this a little bit?
Do you kind of play hard to get?
Do you have an attitude?
What would happen to you?
So sometimes when these entrepreneurs become
very wealthy, powerful,big houses, big cars,
let's just say a lot of influence on social
media.
All these comments on the bottom, you're so
amazing, you're so amazing, you're so amazing.
"I am so amazing.
Therefore, I am better than you."
So that thought becomes entrepreneurs have
to be born, because I am so special and I'm
born.
Another thing that can happen sometimes is
you could be a kid that grew up with a father
who was an entrepreneur.
So his father was an entrepreneur, his father
could have ran a restaurant.
His father could have ran a small business.
His father could have ran something small,
where his father was the one that founded
the business, this kid started working under
his father.
He helped grow his father's business.
So he had an incredible family.
Mom and dad believed in him.
Everything was great, and that gave him this
opportunity to become successful, and he,
in his mind, this is what he believes.
In his mind, the only world he's lived in
is his own world.
He believes for you to become successful,
guess what?
Guess what?
You have to have a very loving family that
they tell you they love you, they're so special.
They're so amazing.
They tell you they love you all this other
stuff.
And, you have to have a father who was an
entrepreneur so that you can go out there
and watch them and because you have an edge
on everybody else, therefore, entrepreneurs
are born.
Is that a good argument?
Maybe he's right.
Maybe she's right.
Now let's look at the other argument, where
the argument is, you know, I believe anybody
can do it.
Anybody can be an entrepreneur.
Or this argument can be, anyone can become
an entrepreneur.
Anyone can become an entrepreneur.
You know, it's good for the economy to believe
that anybody can become an entrepreneur.
Great.
Social media and technology has made the platform
bigger for anybody to become an entrepreneur
because it's so much easier today to start
a business online, whether you're an introvert
or extrovert, you don't have to have a personality
of a salesperson.
You can be a Mark Zuckerberg introvert that
doesn't want all the limelight and you can
design a website and you're worth 60 billion
as an introvert.
Before you had to be a salesperson.
You don't even have to talk to people nowadays
to make a product.
So anybody can become an entrepreneur.
Another one is there are more examples of
success today.
Anytime there are more examples of success,
and a certain platform highlights them.
Today if you go on YouTube and type in "entrepreneur,"
there are so many videos today about entrepreneurship.
If you go on Google and type in entrepreneur,
billions of searches come out about entrepreneur.
What does that tell you?
It is more thought about today than it was
years ago.
So what does that mean?
They make an argument that anybody can become
an entrepreneur.
I want you to think about this.
So, there used to be a time back in the day
where an attractive woman was somebody that
was a bigger woman.
So if you go back and study history of women,
and how men were attracted to women, years
ago it was the bigger the woman, the more
attracted men were to them.
Now why is that?
Why do you think that is?
Because somebody of stature liked bigger women,
and everybody said, if a powerful person likes
bigger women, then I'm to like bigger women.
Then it changed.
And the media started telling us that the
most attractive women in the world are what?
Extremely skinny.
They're 6' 1" and they're 75 pounds.
If you know what I'm talking about.
They're so skinny you see all the bones.
Oh my gosh, this is so beautiful!
Why?
Because Calvin Klein put these magazines out,
everybody's like Zoolander.
Do you know what I'm talking about with the
Zoolander thing?
You see very bone they have.
Oh, she's so sexy!
And then we went away from that.
Do you know what it is today?
Today you have a girl that's got 60 million
followers on Twitter with stacked back here,
so guess what's sexy today?
Voluptuous, thick, curvy, that's sexy today.
I want to have a girl that looks like Kim
Kardashian.
That's what's sexy today, right?
Pat, where are you going with this?
Very simple.
People started body building because of Steve
Reeves.
Reeves was the first what?
I think he was the first Hercules.
He put his arms out, boom!
He had this 19 inch, 20 inch guns.
Everybody wanted to be a bodybuilder.
Then Arnold became a bodybuilder.
Then Arnold went into movies and everybody
wanted to have an amazing body.
So Arnold started an epidemic of wanting to
become what?
Body builder.
That's what he did.
Today, today, Steve Jobs, Zuckerberg, Bezos,
Wozniak, Michael Dell, all these guys Elon
Musk, they are so big today that everybody
wants to become an entrepreneur, which means
what?
Here's what it means.
The school of thought that thinks anybody
can do it, because there are more examples
of people winning, people start to believe,
there are so many people becoming entrepreneurs,
I can also become an entrepreneur.
So belief level has become so high and the
market for competitiveness has become so high,
everyone wants to become an entrepreneur.
Does that mean they're right?
I don't know if that means they're right.
I can't tell you if they're right or they're
not right.
So there is a trend today of entrepreneurship.
Maybe it wasn't the case 30 years ago, 40
years ago because pension plans were around
so much, and everybody wanted to go out there
and land a great job at a big four, and if
I work here for 30 years they're going to
give me a pension plan and I'm set.
I don't need to start a business.
I don't need to start a business and then
boom!
Ten years ago, pension plans are being cancelled.
United Airlines defaults on a big pension
plan.
Oh, we can't do it anymore.
134,000 pension plans go to 20,000 pension
plans in America, then all these people that
were working for a company for 30 years were
saying, why am I working here for 30 years?
I don't have equity.
I don't have stocks.
I don't have profit sharing.
I'm not getting pension.
Why am I doing this?
Maybe I should consider entrepreneurship.
So the school of thought is people are realizing
I need to become an entrepreneur so they're
making a decision to go become an entrepreneur.
So let's stay on that argument a little bit
and have some fun with it.
Let's get silly a little bit.
It's okay.
We'll have some fun here.
But I hope this will make sense to you.
When people say to me, Pat, entrepreneurs
are born.
Here's what I say to them.
I say,okay, you say entrepreneurs are born.
No problem.
A guy named Archie Manning has three kids.
Okay?
He used to be a quarterback, a football player.
He was a quarterback.
He has three kids.
His oldest son, his name is Peyton Manning.
Guess what he ends up doing?
He becomes a quarterback.
Was he born to become a quarterback?
Or is it accidental.
Maybe he was destined to become a quarterback.
And he wins two Super Bowl championships.
Archie's second kid is named Eli.
Guess what he became.
He became a quarterback.
And guess what he did?
He won two Super Bowl championships.
Now what a father.
He got lucky, right?
And the third son, what does he do?
He becomes a quarterback.
Oh my gosh.
Accidental.
No.
There's a reason why they became quarterbacks.
Because their father was the most ridiculous
teacher who taught them to become a quarterback
so they started.
Next thing you know, father wants it and the
Manning family of quarterbacks.
Kennedy, was somebody born to become a politician?
No, the father, Joseph Kennedy had an aspiration
of giving birth, he wanted to go into politics.
So his kids ended up in politics.
He thought Joseph was going to be the one
because he was a super soldier.
He went into the military.
He wanted to fight so hard that he ended up
killing himself in war.
So Joseph, the father, who named his first
son Joe, he was planning on having Joe become
a president.
Joe doesn't become a president, and he's devastated,
and the kid, the underdog nobody would believe
that was going to become the president, John
F. Kennedy, he becomes the president and he
had back problems, health problems, and he
becomes the president.
And one of the most loved presidents.
Then that entire family goes into politics.
Were those kids born to go into politics?
I don't think so.
What happened to that family?
Something happened there.
So in basketball, I'll give you another example.
Let's talk about sports.
If I'm 14 years old, 6' 8" who do you think's
going to come talk to me?
The music teacher?
No.
I want you to think about it.
I'm 6' 8" in school So visualize me.
I'm going through a locker room.
I take these long steps.
You know the way I walk, I'm taking these
long steps.
And then all of a sudden, who spots me?
Basketball coach.
Who's that kid?
Oh, he just moved here from New Jersey.
Oh my gosh!
How old his he?
14.
No, he looks like he's 35.
No, no, he's 14 years old.
I want to talk to him.
Bring him afterwards.
Hey kid, what's your name?
John.
Do you ever play basketball before, John?
No.
Do you like basketball?
It's okay.
Well, we're going to teach you how to play
basketball, kid.
Okay.
Do you want to play for the team?
And have girls like you and cheerleaders?
Yeah, I'll play.
Great.
Come on, we're going to show you.
They give him a ball.
Shoot the basketball.
This kid cannot shoot a basketball.
Shoot a basketball!
He has no clue what he's doing.
Then they work on him, and they put somebody
to work on his footwork, practice, with him.
Teach him defense.
The next thing you know, they have a center
that's 6' 8", 14 years old.
Two years later he's 7' 1".
Two years later he's playing for a college
team for one year.
Two years later he gets a 100 million dollar
contract to play for some team.
There he is.
The next guy.
He's 6' 8".
Was he born to become a basketball player?
No, he's 6'8".
You're a target.
Here's another one.
Let's just say, I'm a kid and you know, I
go to tryout.
I'm doing whatever I'm doing.
And all of a sudden, all the friends are doing
a race.
You know how we are when kids, we want to
compete about anything.
So, hey, who can do a handstand?
So we do a handstand.
I'm terrible at handstands.
Pathetic.
Hey, who can throw a ball?
Someone throws a ball.
Oh my gosh, that guy's got a strong arm.
You remember these things.
Who punches the hardest?
Punch my shoulder.
It won't hurt.
These are stupid things we do as kids.
Punch my shoulder.
Man, this kid hits hard.
There was always that one kid that would hit.
Man, that stings.
Okay, let's see who can jump the longest.
And then this one kid jumps.
He can't jump.
The other one can't jump.
Then one guy comes and jumps.
Oh my gosh, this guy flew!
He's flying!
This guy is a bird!
This is insane!
What happened here?
This guy could. . . he definitely, great grandpa
was a bird or something.
There was an eagle in that family lineage.
Then all of a sudden people find out that
he got a reputation.
Hey, there's Jumpin' Johnny!
Who finds out about Jumpin Johnny?
The track and field coach.
or the volleyball coach.
hey, bring this Jumpin' Johnny guy.
Hey Johnny, show us how much you jump.
Okay, boom.
Holy moly, 40".
Forty inches means what?
Track, volleyball, basketball.
Was he born to go into track?
C'mon, man.
That guy's got a God-given ability, right?
What if I have a quick first step?
What if I've gotten very quick?
With my hands I'm very quick.
This is boxing.
This is good stuff.
What if I'm raised in the streets, ghetto.
Bad areas.
And you've got a bad area boy and you don't
have a choice.
Some people are born in that area.
Where do you think boxers come from?
Who's one of the top boxers, what was his
name?
Tyson is heavyweight, Evander Holyfield came
from light heavyweight and he became eventually
the champion.
Not Mayweather.
Who was the other guy?
That he went to prison.
He was in prison for five years and then he
came out.
Not Durant.
This was an African American.
He's phenomenal.
What's his name?
He had a beard.
Not Roy Jones.
It was another guy.
Anyways, look him up right now while I'm talking.
Pull him up on your phone.
So this guy grew up in the streets and he
has to fight his way to the top.
He had to fight his way to the top.
So all of a sudden everybody's fighting with
this guy and the guy's fighting back.
So all of a sudden everybody knows how to
box, and this guy goes to prison.
In prison he has to protect himself.
He has to protect himself.
So all of a sudden he wins middle weight.
And then he comes out and he starts competing.
He fights until 48 years old.
Cleans up his life and becomes a boxer.
How did he become a boxer?
Here's another one.
Bernard Hopkins.
Okay, so here's another one.
Here's another one.
I want you to think about what it takes to
be a jockey.
Jockey.
Horse jockey.
You know what it is, when they're riding on
the horse.
Can I be a horse jockey?
What if I want to become a horse jockey?
So the argument here - anyone can become an
entrepreneur.
Can I become a horse jockey?
What do you think?
Can I?
I'm 6' 5', 240.
You know what would happen to that poor horse?
That horse would be like, I can't do this
any more.
I give up.
You know what's the ideal height for a jockey?
4' 8, 4' 10 to 5' 6".
You know what the weight is?
108- 118.
Can you imagine that?
So if you weigh 149, you can't be a jockey.
You can't play at that level.
Can you imagine if Shaq, he's 7' 2, 400 pounds.
Can he be a jockey?
He is the horse.
The horse gets on his back.
So try to visualize this, right.
So there are very good arguments on the born
side.
And there are very good arguments on the built
So who is right?
Which argument is right?
Because there are things that we've got to.
. . and I know it sounds a little silly to
you when I'm talking about this.
So let's ask the following question on why
do people become entrepreneurs.
Because this is a very important question
for us to ask.
Why do people become entrepreneurs?
Okay, why do people become entrepreneurs?
So, one, similar to the story I told you about,
with Manning, how, you know, his three boys
become quarterbacks, and not just football,
specific quarterbacks, and he was a quarterback.
His two oldest sons won two championships.
That's insane.
So why does somebody become an entrepreneur.
Because his family or her family were filled
with entrepreneurs.
Donald Trump goes into real estate, his father
was in real estate, Fred Trump.
You know, you see a lot of these, you know,
Kennedy's politics.
You see a lot of this lineage.
Football, football.
So one of the reasons why people become an
entrepreneur is because their family was an
entrepreneur.
So someone may say, I think you have to be
born.
Well, you were born in a family with a father
that was an entrepreneur, so you think everybody
has to have a father that's an entrepreneur
to become an entrepreneur.
My father wasn't an entrepreneur.
And quite frankly, I was born in a Middle
Eastern family, where the first time my dad
told me he loved me, I was 21 years old.
And you know how he did it?
Here's how he did it.
I called my dad one day, and it's not that
he. . . he's very loving.
One of the most loving men I know.
He just doesn't say it.
So one day I pulled my dad aside and said,
"Dad, guess what?"
What's that?
I said, I want to hear you tell me you love
me.
I had just got out of the military.
He said, "Relax, you've become too Americanized.
We're Middle Eastern.
I'm Assyrian.
I don't have to tell you I love you."
I said, "Dad, I want to hear you tell me you.
We need to hear.
Your daughter and son want to hear you say
you love us.
He said, "What is wrong with you?
Have you lost it?
Have you been too Americanized after this
military thing?"
I said, Look, you just need to start saying
it.
Because people need to know.
Your grandkids are going to want to hear you
say I love you.
So I go to work the next day at Bally's.
I get a call.
My dad never calls me at work.
He calls me at work and I said, "Hey, Pop,
what's going on?"
Hey, how you doing?
I'm doing good, Pop.
Hey, I just want to tell you.
What's that, Pop?
I love you.
And he hangs up on me.
That's how he first time he told me he loved
me.
Can you imagine that?
My mother and my dad, they never grew up saying,
"You're going to be so amazing.
You're so special."
Some guys have that.
I don't have that and most of the world doesn't.That
doesn't mean you need to have that perfect
situation to become an entrepreneur.
But that is his argument.
It doesn't have to be your argument.
Okay.
So number one, family.
I know a guy, Pastor Dudley whose entire family
is filled with pastors.
So many of them.
They're all pastors.
Brother's pastor.
Uncle's pastor.
His father's a pastor.
Grandpa.
. . everyone's a pastor.
Were they born to become a pastor?
And they're incredible pastors.
Were they born to become pastors?
No.
Family.
Why did they become an entrepreneur?
Why did they become a pastor?
What football?
Why become a politician?
Family.
#2.
Someone they looked up to.
Someone becomes an entrepreneur because an
uncle, friend, relative, next door neighbor,
whatever it is, they said, "I want to be like
him."
They read a magazine and said, "I want to
be like Rockefeller.
I want to be a movie star.
I watched this movie and he was a financial
adviser, I want to be the next, the legal
version of Gordon Gekko.
I want to Bud Fox and land those big sales.
I want to be the next.
. . they saw somebody that was a successful
entrepreneur and they want to be like him.
#3: it's the only way out.
It's the only way out.
What do I mean by the only way out?
Well, you know, if you're born in the bad
side of school, if you listen to any of 2Pac's
songs, and you actually listen and you read
it - forget about listening to it, you just
read it.
Brenda's Got a Baby.
That script, if you listen to that song Brenda's
Got a Baby, an average person reading that
song is going to say, I can't even listen
to it, it's so painful.
What Brenda's Got a Baby at 12 year's old?
he's tell you a real story of what happens
in that community with a 12 year old getting
pregnant.
That's not a myth.
That happens.
To you maybe never in a million years.
But that happens.
So what is desperation for an entrepreneur?
The only way out is for me to start a business.
I go to Mexico.
And every time I go to Mexico, hey, do you
want to buy gum?
Do you want to buy gum?
Chiclet, Chiclet, Chiclet.
Why are those 6 year olds selling gum?
Desperation.
It's their only way out.
it's their only way out.
They have to make money.
Their parents got three kids, and they're
all selling gum.
Why?
I admire it actually.
See, these kids are growing up learning about
hard work at 5, 6, 7, 8 years old.
They're learning persuasion.
Kid comes up to me, Senor, Senor, they give
you a smile.
They're learning about charm, persistence,
never giving up.
Hey, Chiclet?
Chiclet?
And you look at this kid and it's like, how
can I say no to you man?
Here's a dollar.
That gum costs five cents.
That's 10,000% mark up . Here's a dollar man,
go away, you're good.
Hey, gracias.
And then we walk way.
Desperation.
Entrepreneurship.
There's a level of desperation.
#4, a dream.
This person's got a dream.
I've got a dream.
What's your dream?
I want to live in a better community than
my family lived in.
A dream.
I saw my parents going through a divorce.
I don't want to live that life.
A dream.
We grew up broke.
First time I ever went and had dinner at a
nice restaurant, my mother took us to a Sizzler's
restaurant, I thought everyone in the room
was millionaires.
Millionaires.
Sizzler is nothing.
I go into Sizzler the first time I had any
kind of a nice restaurant is at Sizzlers,
at 18 years old.
My mother did her best.
She didn't have the money.
We go to this restaurant, Sizzlers, I'm sitting
there.
Literally, look how naive I am.
Look how naive I am.
I'm an 18-year-old kid.
I'm looking at everybody and said, Polet,
look, everybody here is rich, man.
And we're having dinner with rich people.
What is Sizzlers?
It was a dream.
First time I had lobster was in the Army.
We went and we had lobster at Red Lobster,
$24, I was oh my gosh, we spent $24 on food!
For one meal.
I've never done that.
So I didn't grow up with a family with a lot
of money.
To me, that was a big deal.
So there's a certain level of dream.
What can we afford.
What if I can feed my parents.
What if they don't ever have to worry about
money.
What if I could.
. . my parent sacrificed, they came to America.
I don't want my dad to ever pay.
. . I want to take my dad and travel all over
the world.
My dad had 13 heart attacks, 6 angiograms,
6 angioplasties, 3 stents in his heart.
Dad, I just want to show you the world.
Man, I just want you to meet your grandkids
one day and I want to have my kids be able
to say they have a relationship with their
grandpa because I never had a chance to meet
my grandpa.
That's a dream!
That gets me where I can cry right now thinking
about it.
Maybe there's a dream.
You don't have to be born.
You can be built.
And it's a dream that motivates somebody to
become an entrepreneur.
Next one.
Finding the right team to run with.
I was at Texas A&M university speaking to
the entrepreneurship society, set up by this
kid named _______ who I believe is from the
Philippines or Thailand, and the last question
the kid asked, Pat, if you could tell us anything
right now before leaving, what could be the
one thing you could tell us.
I said, look, just look at Hollywood.
Hollywood, if you get into a clique of four
actors that do very well to get into movies,
you'll keep doing movies with them.
Just look at groups of people that you'll
see, wow, they've done five movies together.
It's not accidental, it's a team.
This is intentional.
Sometimes a kid accidentally, his name is
Daniel, he finds a guy named Mark, and Mark
starts a website called The Facebook, and
Mark needs money.
Daniel gets 18 grand, gives it to Mark.
They start this company.
Daniel today is worth a couple billion dollars.
Daniel's considered a multi-billionaire entrepreneur.
How did he do it.
Was he born to become an entrepreneur?
No.
It's friends.
It's group of people.
It's a team of people that we're part of.
Accidentally they became an entrepreneur.
Last one is environment, you know, which has
to do with finding the right team, but it's
kind of a different environment.
If you're around other entrepreneurs, you're
going to become an entrepreneur.
If you're around anybody else that plays football,
soccer, basketball, music, guitar, you're
going to pick up some of that.
Generally, there will be an influence on that
for you to be a part of.
So the last one before we wrap up.
So, I do believe and agree with both of them.
Let me give you a complete different argument
I have here.
I do believe when people say entrepreneurs
are born.
They're right.
I also do believe when people say entrepreneurs
are made.
They're also right.
Here's the kicker.
The question isn't about are they born or
made.
At what level, what's their capacity on how
big of an entrepreneur they can be.
So there are three levels.
One is becoming the greatest.
So somebody asked, can I become like Elon
Musk?
No.
Very simple.
This kid, his father, family, they were all
rocket scientists, they thought like that
from, and when he was a kid he thought like
that.
This kid devoured books at 10, 9 years old.
Strange mind he had.
No, you can't be Elon Musk.
But you don't have to be Elon Musk.
He's the greatest.
Can I be Michael Jordan?
No.
Michael Jordan's hands would go around a ball.
Michael Jordan jumped 49 inches, 48 inches.
Michael Jordan was 6'7", with an older brother
named Adrian, I believe, who bullied him playing
basketball and was better than him, so it
kind of pushed him and his dad took a liking
on his older brother.
So Mike's like, you know what dad?
You believe in him more than me?
Watch what I'm going to to.
Boom.
He had a chip on his shoulder.
You can't be Michael.
Mike's got some God-given abilities.
So you can't be the greatest.
Acting.
Johnny Depp.
Can you become Johnny Depp?
No way in the world.
There's only one Johnny Depp.
Give me roles Johnny's played.
Alice in Wonderland.
Chocolate thing - Willy Wonka.
Scissorhands, which is insane.
21 Jumpstreet, Jack Sparrow.
Do you realize the complicated roles this
guy plays?
Someone says, I want to be like Johnny Depp.
Let me simplify it for you.
No.
Very simple.
There's only one of him in seven billion people
around the world.
Very difficult to become a Johnny Depp.
But here's the good news.
Can you become a pro?
Yes.
Just not the greatest.
You can build a business.
And make millions of dollars.
I'm telling you.
You can build a business and make millions
of dollars.
You can go play the game of basketball, and
be 5' 3", 160 pounds, and be Muggys Bogues
playing basketball in the NBA.
You can go play the game of football and be
Warrick Dunn, 5' 7", 5' 8", 170 what is he?
5' 8" 170 running back.
This guy would get popped.
He played for, I don't know, 10 years?
He had a pretty good career.
He's never going to be the greatest.
But he was a pro.
You can go become an actor.
And be in movies.
Are you ever going to be.
. . " No, but you can be a pro and enjoy it.
You can become an entrepreneur, make a half
a million a year or a million a year, 10 million
dollars a year.
You just may not be the greatest.
Who cares?
You wanted to become, your purpose was a different
purpose on why you chose to become an entrepreneur.
And the last one is this.
The last one is fun.
Can I play basketball?
Yes.
Am I any good at it?
No.
Can I learn to have some fun with basketball?
Yes.
Can I be a decent actor and do videos on YouTube
and put it up there and get a few laughs?
Yes.
Of course.
Can I go out there, and you know, start a
business and for fun, and just say, hey, I
like making these little sandwiches because
I like the way everyone likes it when I do
my barbecue, I'm for fun going to start doing
this barbecue on weekends, and see what happens.
You start passing out flyers.
Hey everybody, you got, when I used to make
barbecue, everybody used to show up.
So imagine if I say hey, 200 flyers, pass
them out.
This Sunday I'm doing barbecue from 1:00 - 5:00.
For fun!
Let's do this.
Chicken, $5 a pop.
Let's pass it out.
50 people show up in the community.
I sell 50 chickens for $5, $250, it cost me
30 bucks to make it.
It cost me 30 bucks to make it.
So that's for fun.
You can do that as well.
So the next time someone tells you are entrepreneurs
born or made?
And if they go either way, now you have an
argument on what to do with it.
You've got to redefine it.
Ask them the question, what does it mean to
become an entrepreneur, definition.
Number two, you've got to ask them why they
believe the way they, and why they believe
the way they do, the born or built, number
three, why do people become entrepreneurs,
number four, what level?
There's the greatest, no, they’re right,
you can't become one.
You can become a pro, and anybody can have
fun, becoming an entrepreneur making two to
three grand a month, part time doing an online
thing on eBay.
That still is considered an entrepreneur.
So with that being said, whether you agree
or disagree, it doesn't matter.
Comment on the bottom, with your thoughts,
on if you believe entrepreneurs are born or
entrepreneurs are made.
I really want to hear your thoughts.
And on top of that, first, throw me the first
subscribe pillow.
This is exciting.
This pillow is going to go into the history
books, because this pillow helped us get to
100,000 subs.
We will forever have a very special emotional
moment with this pillow.
If you haven't subscribed to this channel,
I posted a video four or five videos ago that
we were looking for a new pillow to replace
this.
This is going in the pillow hall of fame.
And we're looking for a new pillow for 2017
to use in every single video that we'll do.
And we're already getting a lot of people
sending us pillows.
Here's a couple of them.
Send me that one.
Okay, this is one of them that we just got.
This is from __________________ - he's got
a front and back where it's a black one.
It says subscribe to Valuetainment.
It's got the YouTube logo on it, and it's
got the Valuetainment logo on it.
It's kind of cool.
Here's another one from Michelle Trapp.
She's got subscribe to Valuetainment.
I'm assuming, Michelle, this is how we'd use
it.
From North Carolina, Subscribe to Valuetainment.
Which is kind of cool.
And then this one is a simple one was well,
Valuetainment subscribe, with the YouTube
play button.
I like this, one I dropped.
This is what you call a fumble with a pillow.
Paul - okay, Paul dropped it as well.
Anyways.
Hey, if you want to participate and you want
to send a pillow, and you think you're creative
and you know some people that can make some
custom pillows, send it our way.
The address is 5001 Spring Valley Road, Suite
1155 East, that's in Dallas, Texas 75244.
Send it our way.
We're going to pick one before the end of
the year, and we'll announce who the winner
is.
If we choose yours, we'll give you love in
videos in emails on Facebook.
And then we'll use it for the entire year
of 2017.
Because we have a goal in 2017 of getting
to a million subs.
So if you haven't subscribed, please do so.
Any thoughts about today's video, comment
on the bottom.
Thanks for watching everybody.
Take care.
Bye, bye.